والان سنتحدث عن ما حدث في مدينه سيفاس
وهي احدى المعاقل الهامه المؤيده للرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان والتي ربما يلخص ما حدث
في عموم البلاد بحسب تقرير لواشنطنبو ماذا
قالت الصحيفه قالت ان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اعتمد في تفوقه في هذه المنطقه في
انتخابات الرابع عشر من مايو على من
وصفتهم الصحيفه
بالمتدينين القوميين او بمزيج من الاثنين
بسهوله تامه فاز اردوغان في المدينه
بالجوله الاولى من الانتخابات بحصوله على
69% من الاصوات في سيفا الساب تحالف
اردوغان البرلماني حقق نجاحا جيدا في هذه
المنطقه الا ان حزب العداله والتنميه
والذي ينتمي اليه الرئيس خسر عشرات الاف
من الاصوات منذ الانتخابات الاخيره عام
2018 لكن رغم هذا الكبير مشاهدينا عن مرشح
المعارضه في الجوله الاولى اعتبر البعض ان
محدوديه الخيارات او القلق من المعارضه
دفع باتجاه التصويت لايردوغانم واشنطن
بوست التقت بمواطنين صوتوا
واستطلعت ارائهم واعتبرت احداهن انه في
حال وجود مرشح افضل في المعارضه لكانت
صوتت له بينما انتقد اخر تعهد كليتش دار
اوغلو باطلاق سراح سجناء سياسيين بمن فيهم
صلاح الدين الزعيم السابق لحزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي عضو بحزب الشعب الجمهوري
المعارض في سيباس قاللي واشنطن بوست انه
بينما ركز الحزب على الجانب الاقتصادي
ركز تحالف اردوغان على الخطاب القومي
باتهام كليتش دار اوغلو بالتحالف مع
جماعات ارهابيه وبشكل عام حاول اردوغان في
الفتره السابقه للانتخابات تقديم حوافز
للمواطنين منها مثلا زياده اجور العاملين
في القطاع العام زياده كفاءات الضريبيه
اما الاقتصاد فكان عامل حاسم لسكان ونخبي
سباس التي تصل نسبه البطاله فيها الى 5%
من المواطنين لكن يبدو ان تاثير الاغراءات
الرئاسيه لم يظهر سريعا مع نسبه البطاله
التي اجبرت مئات الالاف من السكان على
مغادره سباس والاستقرار بمدن اخرى في
تركيا بما في ذلك اسطنبول لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات